so
thank you for this opportunity to
present in this session
the work i'll show you today is focus on
an exploratory study directed at
devising a high control analysis
platform
based on high-resolution images
effective by reporting
quantitative morphological phenotypes of
tumor organoids
from organelles to ergonomic levels to
start
with the establishment of this platform
in fact we were interested
on the tumor organoid tract response
phenotype as paradigm
and for this reason we choose pancreatic
ductal adenocarcinoma
or as a disease model videos is a
malignant neoplast involving epithelial
cells of the pancreatic diet
that accounts for almost 95 percent of
pancreatic cancers
the low number of treatment regimens
available a marked resistance to
standard anti-cancer treatments
or oncological surgery only applicable
to a few number of patients
or searching for new therapeutic agents
traditional chemical model systems for
dark screening including a stable cell
lines derived from human tumors
and maintaining two-dimensional to this
culture
in fats are the most extensively used
however 2d monoliths often fail to
recapitulate tumor hallmarks such as
cell to cell
cell to extracellular matrix
communication site
architecture or molecular signaling
factors that
are associated to the 3d configuration
in which tumor cells grow
a way to overcome such limitations is to
apply
a 3d culture method to grow those cell
lines
as multicellular aggregates known as
asparagus
this provides a model system suitable to
integrate on specific mechanisms of
camera resistance
like drug penetrants across multiple
cellular layers
murals and reorganize which can be
defined as microscopic
self-organizing three-dimensional
structures that arise from stem cells
have emerged as a powerful tumor in
additional system
organoids can recreate diseases take
phenotypes from the parental tissue
origin and they also provide a means to
represent the full range of genetic or
phenotypic spectrum
of human patient tumors thus providing a
more
complete model for pre-clinical studies
the throughput of image-based phenotypic
screening
in these 3d models however remains
critically medium if not low
compared to the to the world
and in fact if we examine for example um
studies that aim to um
quantify cytotoxic effects due to the
exposure of drugs
we can observe that usually they are
established uh
based on morphological changes at the
level of the organelles
our asteroids and in fact this is
through the detection
of um multicellular structure shrinking
for such a phenotypic evaluation high
numerical aperture objectives are not
particularly necessary as gross changes
in organoid size or
shelf can be detected from low
resolution images
even the viability of cells within
organoids can be established with the
use of fluorescence that life cell stems
and phenotypic features can be
structured from these patterns of
fluorescence
you can you can see appreciate that in
this
example from the literature from the
root of love
but when the central question is to gain
mechanistic insight
of disease at the cellular level then
accessing to morphological information
at the success levels and not only at
the single level
in fact becomes necessary because in
this case the question is to
interrogate on cellular pathways
the imaging modalities seek indeed for
high numerical aperture objectives that
can provide
organic information beyond individual
structures
but often imaging of immunolabel
organelles
involve immunofluorescence processing as
a sequential step
to the growing of organelles and in fact
this type of approach
compromises this controllability of dsa
on the other side the imaging of
organoids
immunolabeled in situ for example
in a matrix-based substrate like
ubimatri
material can encounter in fact various
sources then of optical operation
light scattering and all this in fact
compromises the retrieval
of high resolution images
so our our goal here is to establish
a high content imaging platform in which
we can combine
visualization of organoids on a
set-by-cell basis
but without sacrificing i say
scalability
then then is to incorporate the
quantitative description of cellular
pathways
into patient-derived organoids
specifically a structural response to
anti-cancer drugs
and the idea is then to use this
information to enable more prognostic
value
to enhance the detailed definition of
chemo resistance but also chemo
sensitivity pathways
understand the mechanism of action do it
in the basis
in a basis of uh every individual
passion
i invite all these to facilitate uh
their creation of pre-clinical drug
screening platforms
to do so we have midnight at the organo
3d culturing
in optical bottom 96 wet plates
in this case we have been using pdo
patient delivered organic lines obtained
from htc under the human cancer models
initiative
these organic lines are routinely
maintained through organic culture
protocols
that have been reported and developed in
fact by hans clever's lab
and in particular
these pdos are derived from tumor biosis
and the population of progenitor cells
and are there grown
in material domes and maintaining a
specific growth factor condition at
medium
that in fact enables the expansion the
expansion and maintenance of the organic
lights
so in our case for military session
uh usually what we do is to dissociate
the cells from organized
and then after counting in fact we
resuspend
a certain number in a drop of material
this drop of material
as you can see in the stand number one
in fact
um is placed onto the bottom of where
that has been cut with a thin
layer of material to facilitate the
positioning of organoids within a
similar set range
which is also important to maximize the
capture
of the number of structures the
organelles are grown in a diluted
mixture of material which in fact
dissolves by application of
uh the chemical fixative as you can see
in a step
number three and that in fact has been a
report in a previous protocol that was
developed for automated imaging of large
sets of column casino asphalts
this platform is indeed uh
can be indeed applied for asphalts and
for
this has been organization main model to
set up the platform
in fact with this it's not only possible
to perform all the steps on the same
platform where the organelles
are grown but this protocol enables
fixation instead of the wells
cool well immunostaining fluorescence
report for example
staining and visualization of markers
based on in fact immunofluorescence and
then imaging of the entire in this case
intact individual structures across
large sets of organelles that have
formed in the wells
now this is one example of the coverage
of one well
utilizing a range of objectives in our
self-wire 8000 system so
imaging in this case in this well of 240
organized using two channels
one set plane that shoots from a set of
maximum projections
can implicate as you can see a different
time and also implicates a different
number of
images or in this case microscopic
fields
so in the case of uh high resolution or
high numerical aperture objectives like
the 40 and the
60x we can actually observe that
uh in this modality that i mentioned it
can take
one hour with with the 60x um
with the 60s objective for only one well
but below you can observe what will
happen
if we move towards a screening mode for
example the screen 9612
was in the in the full play and in fact
um
the time uh dedicated to imaging
scales up uh dramatically so the first
thing that
we needed to that we were addressing was
to establish
a basic imaging regime that
was useful at informing on morphological
changes like organic shrinking as
consequence to
drug exposure or manipulation
of growth factors in the cultural media
and
basically what we establish from this
that is in fact doable
is that three sets of 25 dialect fields
using a 40x
a water dimension objective are
sufficient
to retrieve information of populations
of like this of populations of
more than 100 organics in each well i
repeat that we do
three sets of 25 fields
so after this in fact the orc notes are
segmented using
the acting channel you can do a faladina
staining it's really easy
and the individual sizes can be reported
by
measuring the surface area of the
maximum projection of each object in
this case
the accuracy of our approach is
illustrated here by detection of a
global decrease on individual organic
sites
along the exposure of increasing
dosages of paclitaxel for seven days
i would like to remind that 3d cultural
material
lets two formation of structures that
are heterogeneous in size
and thereby our analytical platform is
directed at culture every
individual not and so capturing the
variations on the whole
population in fact you can see this here
the incorporation of information from a
second level of
object segmentation in this case nuclei
enables to express
chances changes on organic sites in
demographic
terms so the organic size can be
stratified according the number of cells
detected in those maximum projection
sections
and then the effect of organized can be
detected as a shift of the population
in this case in the yellow and the
orange
indicated in yellow in orange you can
see in fact that
under patritak cell the size of the
organoids is decreased
dramatically and in fact there are the
structures that we can
image usually contain 16 cells
they are really small or really ultra
small cell clusters
with one or two cells so that is
indicating in fact that the packet
action
is very is very effective at
reducing and decreasing or causing a
shrinkage of the organelles
but beyond handling populational data
our platform that supports capture of
fine organic details
instead of the west which is what we
wanted
so you can observe here a jet stack of
serial images of a video the bottom to
top distance is in this case 96
microns with a stage of one micron this
is a little bit exaggerated we can also
decrease a little bit there
the spacing but it this in fact
you can see that it enables to resolve
any detail of the organelle architecture
and
create also 3d rendering of these serial
sections
and you can observe here with the
pattern mystery as indicated by a better
distribution of cell polarity markers
such as things such
as such as reacting show here in red
you can see in fact that we can really
resolve a woman and
every architectural feature
of the organelles then with this is also
possible to break down the organoid into
different anatomical parts if we want a
part of course of
individual um in
jet planes from a stack
up to 10 microns for example it is
possible to achieve
further object segmentation levels that
includes
single cells and organelles an example
that will report here
of organelle is the endoplasmic
reticulum
and in particular the marker the the
organelles have been assigned for
protein this will feed
isomerase in this case you can see that
how nicely we can
resolve with high detail and all the
features
at the suporganoid level and what is
indicated as eclipse there is in fact
the mass
tailored around the region of interest
in this case the the
er and depending on the staining of the
specific macro and
with this high detail in fact it's also
possible to
determine organic parameters that
include also
the lumen this is what we have
called an organographic or organography
because we can't really segment at the
subordinate
level any detail and in fact this
enables to report
precise measurements of population of of
objects inside the organelles
like cell by cell population nuclei and
also
and retrieve their sizes this is this is
what we wanted to achieve and it's
important that we can show that we can
do so
so in fact with this we can uh describe
variation
across various organized regions
but also we can directly compare the
sizes of
or of the section of the organic of the
cells in that section
on the cellular compartments including
the nuclei
and in fact we can also apply
organography
to describe more in deeply
the response to that exposure as i said
in our case we have been using a smaller
packet texture
this is a microtubule stabilizing track
as you
know very well and in fact from our
demographic analysis we observe that it
causes a dramatic decrease in the organ
of
size um this now we can say also
that this is linked to the loss of the
lumen
but also to an increase in the average
size of cells
in the in the organoid remnants and
probably is reflecting
the defects in mitosis caused by this
uh by this perturbation
in fact this is for example also um
reflected by the if we plot the
correlation
between the surface area of the maximum
projection and the number
of the nucleus that are within that
section you can see here
uh what happens in a control population
of
organelles those that were adjusted with
the mso
so basically under as part of the drug
response we can really detect here
um as a slight reaction but
indeed a deviation of the correlation of
these parameters
that is in fact indicating not only the
sensitivity of their the quality of the
parameters that we use
but in fact is actually a good indicator
a fast indicator
of changes caused by drugs so
this is really good but unfortunately
high resolution imaging
carries an enormous data volume this is
basically something that you have you
are aware
and in fact is one of the bottlenecks of
high resolution 3d imaging so the number
of images that are necessary to obtain
detailed information or quality
parameters as
as i reported in the previous slide in
fact
the number of data that we need scales
up
the number of images especially if we
start like
um integrating the number of fields
in in a in a whole well this is really
dramatic to show that
because this is integrating that all the
fields that cover
one well if then we start also adding
uh the number of set of planes that we
need to
obtain uh more detailed information
um and also the number of channels if we
want to integrate for example
four fluorescents uh channels and now in
fact we are
we are working on addressing this
bottleneck because it's possible to do
so
with a sort of selective imaging
strategies but in some
i hope that i convinced you about the
possibility
and the potency of application of high
resolution high control analysis
to resolve organic phenotypes to more
organized
in particular and that this is possible
really at multiple
scales and a bright future is ahead
and with this in fact i would like to
thank
uh first of all the organizer for
providing me this
opportunity and my
my pi in the high to put bioscience
center that is tarashenk
all my colleagues in the htv and also
my colleagues in the chen lab and in
particular i would like to
thank the the cooperation with dwayne
korea
and jinbu to develop this platform
and then i want to thank you for your
attention
and i will be really happy to take your
questions
thank you very much
great that was excellent talk thank you
so much
marisol can you hear me
having some quick technical difficulties
here please bear with us a second
leave my legs for just one moment
so it seems like we have unfortunately
some technical difficulties
with our speaker's microphone here
um so please do submit questions written
and
i can uh read out the
the written answer questions that um
that the speaker
has answered for you guys sorry the
beauties of doing live live programming
uh we did have one question asking what
kinds of organoids
were used here and these were pancreatic
adenocarcinoma organelles
we had another person ask how did you
decide to make six different categories
of size
why not seven why not three um
and the answer to that question was
that she worked based on the basis of
doubling number of cells
applying those categories it was easy to
handle the data but more categories
could have broken down
just one moment here and um
so another question that we have from
the audience
is sufficient to differentiate between
cells
or is a cell membrane marker necessary
during the masking and segmentation step
wait just a second for our speaker to be
able to
[Music]
respond
[Music]
so for differentiating between the cells
appears actin was the only thing that
was actually used so some membrane
marker was not necessary during the
masking
segmentation step
oh so
the last question that we'll try to
answer here and then people can still
submit written questions and then we'll
wrap up and move on to our next speaker
is how do you ensure high-resolution
imaging at
different depths do you see limitation
in the imaging deaths
deaths
sorry waiting for our written answer
take something
uh so the the in answer to the question
how do you ensure high resolution of
imaging at different depths dc
limitation in those depths
uh it sounds like you're really limited
by the microscope that you're using
in this case it was a confocal hds and
so you were able to get
reasonably far in with still maintaining
your your focus and your christmas
um you if you were working on this sort
of pattern with other kinds of
microscopes you might experience
different imaging tradeoffs at different
depths
you would need to assess this for the
exact system that you're actually using
apologies for the technical difficulty
folks um we'll try and
see if we can get some other questions
answered via text
and thank you all very much and thank
you for the talk